l'actu aujourd'hui premier octobre c'est
la démission de Jacques lollywoz lélus
socialiste à Magny-les-Hameaux a décidé
de passer la main en cours de mandat
vendredi dernier un conseil municipal
s'est tenu un nouveau maire a été élu
reportage Johanna Caudry
ce conseil municipal est un conseil
particulier
une page de l'histoire de notre commune
se tourne
près 35 ans de dévouement Jacques
lolliose a choisi de permettre le
renouvellement dans la stabilité et la
continuité Bertrand Houillon a été élu
maire de Magny-les-Hameaux lors d'un
conseil municipal exceptionnel vendredi
28 septembre après quatre mandats
Jacques claudios a décidé de
démissionner pour laisser sa place à un
ancien maire adjoint pour moi il est
important que donc on puisse passer donc
à une autre génération de quelqu'un qui
avait effectivement donc la bonne
connaissance donc de la ville et parce
que donc être maire donc vous savez ces
six ans 6 ans ses cours et c'est long à
la fois si on veut réaliser il faut donc
s'orienter
nouveau maire s'engage à défendre les
services publics et notamment la Poste
qui menace de supprimer le service de
tri et de distribution sur la ville lors
de ce conseil exceptionnel Bertrand
Houillon a vite endossé son rôle de mère
pour remettre la médaille d'or de la
ville à Jacques lolliose au-delà de
l'émotion de la gauche l'absence de
l'opposition s'est fait remarquer aucun
des cinq conseillers municipaux de
l'opposition n'était présent vendredi
soir qu'est-ce que ça veut dire c'est ça
la démocratie c'est ça la démocratie
donc il y a une convocation de conseil
municipal pour lire le nouveau maire et
donc ces gens donc ce défaut se
complètement ça veut dire que finalement
il n'accepte pas finalement qu'il y ait
une majorité donc au niveau d'un côté
municipal il n'accepte pas qu'il puisse
y avoir des changements un déni de
démocratie à son tour évoqués par le
collectif Mani nouvel énergie dans un
communiqué manie nouvelle énergie
collectif visant au renouveau politique
de manileamo dénonce un véritable déni
de démocratie et rappelle à Jacques
lolliose Bertrand Houillon et l'ensemble
de l'actuel majorité de gauche que les
seuls qui trancheront seront les Manic
et manicoises en mars 2014 lors des
élections municipales outre le maire un
nouvel adjoint a été élu à l'urbanisme
et au logement j'entends serai les
devenus le 8e adjoint de Bertrand
Houillon
et que pensez-vous du départ de Jacques
lollios de cette démission qui avait
vous pensé de son action durant son
mandat à vos réponses recueillies dans
les rues de sa ville Magny-les-Hameaux
je trouve le bilan plutôt positif il a
fait pas mal de choses pour sa commune
pas mal d'animation pour les jeunes pour
pour les enfants aussi
il a fait pas mal de trucs je pense
qu'il a pas mal
il a bien géré un petit peu la commune
et enfin le il y a pas mal il a un petit
peu rénové il y a pas mal de choses qui
ont été faites donc je pense que
globalement le bilan est positif il
était vraiment proche des gens donc
je suis un peu déçu qu'il soit parti
mais bon c'est son choix et pourquoi
elle a fait cela c'est ça que je
comprends pas parce que lui on l'adorait
quoi on l'adore se manif franchement
quoi moi j'ai voté pour lui depuis
toujours ça résume
l'ancien et le nouveau maire de la ville
de Magny-les-Hameaux seront sur le
plateau de tvfils sur le plateau du 7 8
demain mardi à 18h en direct nous
poursuivons ce point sur l'actualité
locale avec une page de sport la grande
classique la 35e édition de la grande
classique c'était ce week-end le Paris
Versailles a accueilli 25000 coureurs
c'est un record nos équipes étaient
forcément présentes résumé de la course
avec Anthony Rech je suis assez étonnée
en fait je pensais que ce serait plus
dur que ça on m'avait dit voilà beaucoup
de choses m'a dit que c'était assez dur
qui est beaucoup de côtes donc voilà je
suis parti avec un rythme assez
tranquille
fait désormais partie de ses milliers
d'amateurs qui font la popularité des
cours sur route parisienne loin derrière
les grands favoris Kenyans Ethiopiens
dont zaoudé tes Balou vainqueur au
sprint en quelques 47 minutes notre
journaliste franchit la ligne de sa
première course avec beaucoup de fierté
très fier non vraiment je me suis
vraiment dépassée je le faisais pour moi
parce que j'ai couru toute seule je
devais pas la faire au départ et puis je
me suis dit bon allez on verra bien
voilà je n'étais pas là pour faire un
temps j'étais juste là pour la finir et
puis et puis nous prouver des choses on
va dire et je suis vraiment je suis
vraiment heureuse une classique comme
Paris Versailles ce n'est pas seulement
bien courir le jour J c'est le type de
course que l'on prépare minutieusement
pour pouvoir pallier à tout coup de
fatigue sur le parcours c'est la
première course je m'étais bien
entraînée j'avais suivi les conseils de
mon coach qui se reconnaîtra voilà une
bonne alimentation bien s'hydrater c'est
vrai que je pensais pas que tout ça tout
ce qu'il y a autour en fait l'hygiène de
vie c'était aussi important que ça juste
avant le dernier ravitaillement j'ai un
petit coup de mou et puis il y avait des
il y avait toute une troupe de
marathoniens derrière moi là qui sont
mis à crier à chanter je me suis dit bon
allez je les suis et puis ça va me
remettre dedans puis après il y avait
des sucres ravitaillement et c'était bon
ils étaient près de 25000 au départ
21200 sont allés au bout de ce 35e Paris
Versailles et Alice Gastine a respecté
ses objectifs en franchissant la ligne
après une heure 43 d'efforts sa
prochaine échéance est déjà dans
quelques jours la journaliste s'alignera
sur le 10 km de parcourir Montigny
peut-être déjà piqué par le virus de la
course à pied
dans un instant nous reprendrons le
cours de cette édition spéciale du 7 8
ici Porte de Versailles pour le salon 2
l'Automobile 2012 auparavant toujours un
mot de sport pour vous repréciser que
trappe a joué son premier match de la
saison samedi soir à domicile en
National de c'est du basket les hommes
du président Jean-Christophe Viron
souhaitait se rassurer après avoir
enregistré une lourde défaite courte
mais lourde des fêtes en début de
championnat à l'extérieur ce n'est pas
contre Berg que trappes pourra lancer sa
saison par une victoire menée 47 22 à la
fin du second carton presque à la dérive
face au joueur nordiste les Trappistes
se dirigés vers une seconde défaite
consécutive en championnat c'est alors
qu'un groupe de jeunes visiblement
supporters du PSG se saisit d'un
extincteur et s'en sert dans les
tribunes et visiblement où ils ont dévié
c'est à la mi-temps ou tout comme tout
le monde en fait et était en train de se
restaurer ou à la buvette et c'est à ce
moment-là je pense qu'ils sont voilà
qu'ils ont joué avec les tracteurs les
salariés du club auront beau tenté de
nettoyer le parquet en vain les arbitres
décident de suspendre la rencontre
de nettoyer de nettoyer toute la surface
toute la surface
d'une jugée que la surface était
dangereuse et puis donc il y avait quand
même la poudre
au niveau de l'air c'est donc ça
devenait ça devenait un jouable un
dossier disciplinaire devrait être
ouvert par la Fédération le SCP risque
une amende voire même une suspension de
terrain en plus évidemment de la défaite
face à Berck le club de trappe devrait
porter plainte
voilà pour ce point sur l'actualité du
1er octobre dans les Yvelines et on
poursuit cette page spéciale cette
édition spéciale du 7 8 sur TVfil 78
consacré au Salon de l'automobile